le festival de cannes et la croisette a
été très ému touché même par l'émotion
qui se dégage du film de nanni moretti
la chambre du fils qui raconte le
traumatisme que représente la
disparition d'un enfant au sein d'une
famille et pour la première fois
l'enfant chéri du cinéma italien ne
signe pas un récit autobiographique
dominique poncet christophe hillary
l'homme qui a bouleversé la croisette
aujourd'hui le voici
c'est nani moretti les habitués du
festival le connaissent c'est la
neuvième fois que le réalisateur italien
vient à cannes
la dernière fois il sert et son fils
dans ses bras aujourd'hui il a la tribu
de son film derrière lui image
symbolique du changement qui s'est opéré
chez ce cinéaste il ne tournait que des
films autobiographiques à la première
personne
aujourd'hui il s'efface la chambre du
fils qui entre ce soir en compétition
traite de la pire des dévastations celle
provoquée par la mort d'un enfant au
sein d'une famille heureuse
la plus grande difficulté quand on
aborde les thèmes de la douleur du deuil
et de l'absence c'est d'éviter le pathos
et le mélo j'ai dû beaucoup travailler
les dialogues pour arriver au réalisme
et à la vérité de l'interprétation dans
son film le réalisateur s'est réservé le
rôle du père
il a offert à la beauté grave de la
horra morante celui de la mer
finale b la bosse vraiment ce qui m'a
séduit c'est l'honnêteté c'est à dire le
la la délicatesse et la et la vérité de
traiter un sujet comme ça sans être
manipulateur c'est pas faussé c'est pas
faux et c'est justement pour cela que ce
film bouleverse rien n'est appuyée tout
est suggéré ce matin à la sortie de la
première projection les spectateurs ne
cachaient pas leur émotion
on sort de là on est tu veux retourner
je peux pas en parler justement parce
que ça me touche beaucoup trop ce très
très subtil c'est par petites doses
et c'est une réussite à la
traditionnelle séance photo nanni
moretti et son équipe sourit ils ont
toutes les chances de figurer dimanche
au palmarès